back on may 24th hogwarts legacy
community manager chandler wood posted
on the playstation blog alongside a
social media update for the game which
largely focused on some special features
for the dual sense controller within
that blog post however there were a few
clips that i think some people may have
missed i've seen a few folks in the
comments asking where i found certain
footage for the game so here's
everything they shared within that post
and while most people were excited about
everything we saw there there was a bit
of concern that emerged from the second
clip here which showed off a new
character model in slytherin robes and a
combat scene from the game now there
were two parts that caused some people
to get a little worried and the first is
the robe physics here or lack thereof
notice this section of the gameplay
trailer here and we can see rogue
physics clearly in place compare that to
this brief shot here nowhere near the
same so it was very nice to see chandler
take to twitter this week to address
those concerns by sharing some new
footage of the game confirming that
rogue physics are alive and well in
hogwarts legacy and they aren't going
anywhere this is awesome to see and
personally i would add that i think the
rope physics and movement actually look
much better here than they did even in
the gameplay trailer just a few months
ago and to me this is a fantastic sign
for the progress of the game frankly
it's something i always try and remind
people of when we see footage of these
games it's a vertical slice you just
never know unless it's outright stated
the settings they're running on the
difficulty level what they do and don't
have disabled clearly we don't even see
a hud here which personally i like but i
think the final version of the game will
definitely have some sort of hud by
default now i did mention there were two
concerns that sprang from that brief
clip we saw on the playstation blog post
and the other one is this guy here on
the left side of the screen is it a bug
is it bad ai i don't know one thing we
can say for sure is that it was shown as
part of an unfinished version of the
game guys so i don't think there's any
reason to be concerned about it just yet
at this point i just find it more
humorous than anything else who knows
maybe chandler will share another video
soon addressing that one as well and i
gotta say i think they're continuing to
do a fantastic job with ramping up the
marketing for the game as we move closer
toward launch i love that we're seeing a
steady stream of content even when it's
small updates like this to me i think
fans love the steady updates like this
and i really want to commend chandler
and the team at avalanche for being
willing to share these little details as
things progress we are still keeping our
eyes out for something big later this
summer which was promised by chandler
just a few weeks ago we didn't see any
sign of hogwarts legacy at the summer
game fest and honestly at this point i
think we can pretty much forget about
seeing hogwarts legacy at any of these
industry-wide shows unless it's
something put on by playstation every
single time we've seen a significant
chunk of the game it has been heavily
promoted and pushed by playstation it
started with the ps5 reveal where
hogwarts legacy was officially revealed
as well for the first time then again in
a dedicated state of play just for
hogwarts legacy and finally here in this
recent update from chandler with the
blog post and the video focusing on the
dual sense features now there actually
was a mention of hogwarts legacy on some
new materials from microsoft as well i
think a lot of people may have missed
this one too but if you check out the
official xbox twitter account they
shared this image that has a list of
what's coming to xbox and pc over the
next 12 months on the left you have 2022
and then on the right 2023 but in the
last row on the 2022 side we do indeed
see hogwarts legacy listed there so
confirmation it is still coming to xbox
and it is still on track for 2022. as
for the actual release date we still
don't know when although there have been
some hints within the amazon uk listing
of the hogwarts legacy art book that art
book at least on that uk listing has a
december 6th release date now even if
that is totally accurate that doesn't
necessarily mean that the game is for
sure coming out that day either but i
gotta say honestly that is my personal
guess for when i think hogwarts legacy
is going to release i think december 6
tuesday that is the day at least in my
opinion and fellow hogwarts legacy
youtuber expect a go actually did a
video on this recently and he was kind
enough to ask me to participate among
several other hogwarts legacy creators
that was a super fun video i definitely
encourage you all to check it out you
can see it on the right side of your
screen now and if you're new here don't
forget to hit that subscribe button
before you go as we are closing in on 25
000 subs thank you all for the love as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon